there is a new traffic signal this
morning at a dangerous intersection this
is in the east valley at sahara and
winterwood
there was a deadly crash there just last
night hector mejia they're live now with
the details good morning hector
hiller alex good morning and drivers
here are getting used to this brand new
intersection you don't see many drivers
out right now but when
we can hear them traveling and we can
see them and as they travel
you can sort of hear how fast they're
going and joining us live we have clark
county commissioner
tech segger bloom to talk about the
efforts to slow down drivers here
in the east valley good morning to you
sir good morning so tell us about this
intersection the
traffic signal was in the works for a
number of years
correct obviously as the valley gets
bigger
uh traffic on these main roads like
sahara is is increasing
and so over the time we've wanted to put
this in this light here but it just
takes time
but uh this is about two year process
and about six months of construction but
we're finally finishing
tragically it's the day after that
accident yesterday but hopefully going
forward will prevent future accidents
and on that note we are working to make
the uh
east valley or just the entire valley a
lot safer for people
safer and also but let people that live
in the east valley get out of here and
go to work
so i'm working on interchange at 95 and
sahara
things like that to make it easier for
people to work here but we also need to
just slow down the traffic as you can
see people's speed
here because that's that's what we do in
las vegas
and just uh around six o'clock this
morning was when we officially turned on
this traffic signal
with a flip of the switch here yeah we
put that
switch there and off we go so it's
amazing how
there's a point of time when it actually
happens but but this is a
this hasn't just happened it's been many
years in the works
and lastly we talk about enforcement we
talk about traffic signals all the time
but the main message for drivers is to
really
be more cautious absolutely i mean at
the end of the day there's nothing worse
than being in a traffic accident
and then the loss of life too so just
everybody needs to slow down and
enjoy itself because the other day how
fast you get somewhere is not going to
make a difference
thank you very much for your time and
for sticking around reporting live
hector mejia
8 news now